I have no romance for any
marketing or business behavior
and never will
'til the day I die. Period.
And that's a very important
statement that so few
in this room actually,
deeply believe.
And if you did, then you would
never disrespect anything new
that has 150 million
active monthly users
like Snapchat
because it doesn't have a
click out function so you
can figure out what
the conversion rate is.
The reason I am going
to make billions and
have made hundreds
of millions and the reason
many in here will make millions
is 'cause there's a difference
between sales and transactions
and brand and marketing.
If you just realized it was
in your best financial interest
to take 20% of your monies
and behaviors and learn
new things and learn 'em.
You would make so
much more success
out of your businesses.
(upbeat techno music)